um but hopefully we can watch the lust
oh wait we already watched the last game
oh this is an amazing game how could i
oh my god i missed i missed the action
oh damn i missed the berlin refutation
ah
crap horrible start to the day i missed
i i missed this fascinating game um
so wait a second so what's the score
what's going on
are they going to a tie break
yes yes they're going to the blitz
playoffs nice
so this is what this is what the rumors
are about
[Music]
v4 oh my god
he played b4 that's hilarious wait did
he play before is this actually real
this is really played b4
that's funny now b4 is not such a bad
move by the way
um before you you bury him
are they like it's just.com glitch okay
there we go
this is called the sekulsky opening um
or the pull in russian it's called the
sikolski opening named after alexis
sakolski
it's basically b3 but you're you're
grabbing more space so what could be
better than that
um it's not refutable it's
it's not that bad i mean it it i would
say the position is closer to equal than
anything
the problem with this move is that this
pawn becomes a weakness and
oftentimes it's advanced to b5 in order
to grab space but that could backfire
because it also creates i wouldn't say
that
i mean it's not a tricky opening
actually it there's no tricks it's it's
you can try to get an advantage with it
a positional advantage by grabbing space
on the queen side it's
it's a positional opening uh it's unlike
the grub which is g4 and that's opening
for trips
so here knight f3 you can see that
white's position is fine i mean there's
nothing wrong with this e6 a3
bishop d6 i assume from wesley i mean
wesley is also in great shape here
i don't see how magnus is going to be
winning this game though
well b4 is not great it's positional but
it's not good
positional doesn't mean good and black
has many ways to get a nice position
against it yeah avoiding the theory and
stuff
i i just want to like caution that
before people are like why is magnus
trolling like
i would not call it a troll opening uh i
would not call it a full-fledged troll
opening so thank you
liam rem so here choice for magnus the
pawn is hanging you have to decide are
you going to play a3 to defend the pawn
or are you going to play b5 and grab
space on the queen side
i anticipate a3 but then wesley could
try to undermine the pawn with a5
because the problem with beef
yeah so i think wesley might go a5 here
and try to get magnus to go b5 to give
wesley the c5 square potentially for his
knight
that's a very common technique in such
positions to go a5 and
or even c5 similar idea
and i think wesley probably made a tiny
bit better here
um c6 wesley going for the solid
approach he keeps this in reserve
i i think a5 might have been a little
bit more challenging for white but
okay c4 by magnus grabbing space
still a5 seems quite interesting but
then magnus already could contemplate c5
then already magnus could contemplate c5
bishop d6 wesley prioritizing his
development you're probably going to see
them both castle maybe magnus is going
to go to d4
wesley going for the sort of london e
kind of slav set up but he's got no
light squared bishop which is what makes
this so good for black normally in such
positions black has the problem of the
light square bishop which is
you know surrounded by its own pawns
here you don't have to worry about that
and if magnus plays d4 then his own
bishop is going to get kind of bad but
if he doesn't play d4 then wesley could
also play e5 and grab space so magnus
going for d3
uh so he's trying to keep his bishop
open
and there's a5
and now a big decision for magnus is
this he goes c5 here i anticipate that
he will i think he'll go c5
um but he could also i assume go
b5 no he goes c5 there we go
wesley will drop the bishop back i
assume to c7
and then you're going to get this very
close center equal position i assume i
imagine
i'm not going to be you know i hate
sounding like this i i feel like wesley
should have gone a5 a little bit earlier
because now magnus has got this pawn
chain and now he can complete his
development so wesley's probably going
to castle as well
from the perspective yeah so castles
castles now magnus has to develop this
knight knight bd2 is the typical way
you could play knight c3 but then that
would block in the bishop a little bit
that's not a big deal though so i think
either
developing move is fine if you know you
want to play more ambitiously you could
also consider e4
grabbing more space in the center um
but wesley up on time
i think you know all said and done
magnus has got a nice position out of
the opening
and if wesley plays e5 i assume then
magnus will meet that with e4
so they're playing i think two tie
breaker blitz games right or is it four
is it two or four b6 and now probably d4
two okay that's what i thought and now
another dilemma you can see how many
decisions
magnus could also take on b6 and then
the c6 pawn becomes a little bit weak so
what you could do
is you could start harassing the c pawn
on the other hand this breaks down
white's pawn chain which is kind of nice
so if magnus wants to keep that he can
play d4 the drawback of d4 is that the
bishop on b2
is blocked in this position these types
of positions also arise in the queen's
game this looks very drawish to me
wesley could play b5 and lock things up
i feel like cb is the more ambitious
attempt yes
now wesley could try to free up the
position with c5 so magnus could still
go d4 here
trying to fix the weakness on c6
if rook fc1 i think wesley wants to go
c5 and just basically make a draw
this is a totally symmetrical pawn
structure
um so we'll see what magnus wants to do
here
knight b3 is also a possibility trying
to swing the knight around to d4 into
the center
um i'm gonna close the nepo game i don't
really
care about that right now this is five
plus
two i think yeah i think there is so
magnus down to two minutes
he's taking a little bit too long here
he's taking a little bit too long here
rook fc one played and as i was saying
c5 here
would invite a trade which would lead to
a symmetrical pawn structure wesley
could
refrain from c5 to play rook c8 here um
no he takes okay so i think he'll
probably trade everything first and then
go c5
or even go c5 here um
what you don't want to do is you don't
want to leave yourself with this pawn
being weak because
it's queen e7 okay so i guess he counter
attacks white's pawn on b4 that makes
sense too
which is isolated i don't know i thought
c5 was
pretty straightforward path to equality
rook ab1
by magnus so he gives wesley the a file
indirectly defending the pawn so wesley
could not take on b4
because the bishop takes f6 discovered
attack against the queen
now he takes on f6 anyway and i think
magnus is going to follow up with d4 and
i'm telling you this pawn on c6 is going
to become a fixed weakness
and that might start bothering wesley
because you won't be able to play c5 if
white has pawns on c4 on b4 and d4
um well thanks i mean
everybody chooses what they like but i
appreciate it
now what is this counter balanced by
this is counterbalanced by two things
wesley's got control of the a file for
now so he could try moves like rook a2
in the future
and of course magnus's pawn on b4 is
also isolated so it's weak
and there comes d4 now magnus wants to
play knight e5
the plans for both sides are well
particularly the plan for white is
pretty straightforward you want to
attack this pawn
wesley with a clever move you cannot
take it because the bishop takes h2
check
where is the bishop going i think the
bishop is going to d6
and wesley is trying to mount a direct
assault against magnus's weakness so
magnus at any point if he wants to bail
out he can play b5
if he wants to bail out and make a draw
he can play b5 this leads to a trade
totally symmetrical position draw
with minute and a half on the clock
maybe it's time to do that
okay so knight e1 bishop d6 knight d3
may be possible too
if you want to defend the spawn this
seems a little bit passive this
i love this move this is an amazing move
and
i think that with every ticking second
magnus is more tempted to play b5
here and just bail out a minute on the
clock already 18 moves in no knight e1
played he does go for 91
very brave what bothered me about this
bishop d6
knight d3 and maybe wesley can slam
his rook into a2 i don't know things get
heated here after something like b5
i think this is probably still equal
from a objective perspective but it
doesn't matter e5
is possible here as well
no so this happens bishop d6 knight d3
now rook a2
wesley going rook b8 he's going after
this pawn
knight f3 magnus not going for the
implicit draw for after bishop before i
think he wants this move he wants to
take the spawn
on his own terms he wants to take it
with a fork he doesn't just want to take
the pawn
uh because you could take the pawn with
your rook but then wesley would take on
before and that rook is neither here nor
there
he wants to take it with a knight look
at how
deftly magnus is swinging his knights
around wesley might have to go knight d7
and cover the square one more time
to to not permit white's knight to come
to d5 okay no he goes for b6
now knight e5 seems very tempting
there it is and i don't know what
wesley's planning here he gets his queen
b7 maybe
i guess mostly was planning queen b7 so
black trying to defend the spawn as well
as he can while preserving
pressure on b4 there it is
and i like what wesley just did there
i guess magnus could try queen c2
continuing to pile up on that pawn
what you don't like about that is the
fact that the queen is ahead of the rook
normally you want that flipped wesley's
threatening to take on b4
so magnus could also defend that pawn
there comes queen c2
okay now bishop takes b4 needs to be
calculated by wesley i don't know what's
going on here knight c6 this gets crazy
wesley going after the knight instead
so 95 rook before this is probably going
to fizzle out into a draw
magnus still trying to play for when he
takes of the pawn
this is very risky he's got 30 seconds i
guess he wanted knight c5
wesley dropping the knight back to a
very solid defensive square
rook b3 magnus playing slowly what
magnus is saying here is that the knight
defends the pawn on b4
he wants to triple on the c file and
continue to pressure the c6 pawn that's
been the
whole game has revolved around white's
ability to attack that pawn
wesley i don't think is in crisis mode
yet he could always put his rook on c8
but that's a little bit passive
but he goes after goes for c5 the
bailout move
how does this work what's the move now
he's down a pawn
i guess wesley should probably make some
look for his king at some point
so that he doesn't have to worry about
the back rank mate and then
i guess he's going to try to go after
white's pawn but oh
rook c6 oh my god
it's white's background i should have
seen that oh my goodness
magnus just wondered his queen he missed
rook c6 and he can't take because of the
backrank mate
oh my goodness it backfired on him oh
that's beautiful
wesley does create some lift but first
he wins white's queen this is over
black is winning magnus is
over ambition here backfires we're okay
five and the rest is easy black just has
to win this pawn
and with so many puns remaining on the
board there's really no way to build a
fortress i think you can just take on b5
here
check here then you give a check on b1
you go queen b2
and you win everything here i think
wesley is just verifying that that is
possible
wow wesley instead going very solid g6
creating more lift i don't think that
was necessary
but he doesn't want to give magnus any
kind of chances
g7 very very methodical
h4 i'm not sure why what i'm missing
here after rook b5 honestly
why did wesley not just take the pawn
i don't know that's weird but anyways
this is still completely winning queen
b8 is going after this pun
the one thing to watch out for this pawn
on b5 is pretty far advanced i
still think you can take on e5 this is
impossible because you dropped the rook
queen takes e5 rook c1
and uh black has to contain the spawn
that's the one thing to do rook a7 rook
b7
is is one one way of doing that rook a2
is another so b6 by magnus seems forced
there it is how is wesley going to stop
the pawn queen f5 broke f1
i guess he's gonna just go rook aid rook
b8
not a huge fan of that approach but
rook takes f2 maybe this rook takes f2
work i think it does
rook f2 b7 rook f1
this happens and queen e5 and then
you're gonna take on g3 and swing back
to b
this is over yes perfectly executed by
wesley
and magnus is about to resign because
after rook b1 wesley doesn't even need
to go back to b8 immediately he can take
all of white's pawns with check
and either he forks the rook or worse
comes towards you just come back around
to b8
and then uh you use your king to take
that pawn and magnus is resigned
and magnus is going to be kicking
himself or declining
multiple implicit draw offers d e was
the
was sort of the first mistake and then
c5
by wesley is an incredible move how do
you see this
so quickly now i had a question here if
bc and c6 this was also interesting
this was interesting by magnus sacking
the rook and going instead after the
night
i'm not seeing the defense right off the
bat here queen b5 cd i'm sure the engine
is laughing at me
but i guess rook d8 and black is fine
but this would have been very very close
but instead magnus going knight takes c5
takes takes and this move rook c6 i also
i mean i forgot that why did i i assume
magnus had played h3 for some reason
but he didn't um and again if he takes
the rook
then you take and you get checkmated on
the back rank
and uh this move d takes e5 i think 95
would have led to a quick draw
sorry i keep doing that oh my bad um
in this position knight e5 brook b4 rook
before queen b4 knight c6
and you can offer a draw i mean it's
literally symmetrical piece
uh composition and structure
and this just shows you that you know
these tactical themes can come
totally all of a sudden wesley's got to
be pumped if he draws the next game with
white he wins the match
and he wins the final
oh man that's crazy well it wasn't
because of b4 i mean i think a lot of
people on facebook are probably going to
be blaming this on b4 but that's not why
magnus lost he actually got a pretty
nice position
magnus got a pretty nice position wesley
was on his back foot a little bit
nothing major um but this
yeah knight takes c5 was the reason
um magna wesley has just got magnus's
number
this is kryptonite
what's the worst table etiquette you've
seen i mean i've seen people like knock
the pieces off and stuff
um i think that some kids i've played
they like
they will deliberately make tons of
noise at the board like they'll sniffle
and cough
but not because they have a cough but
because they want to distract you
i think nepo is going to well nepo's got
a lot of time
i think physical fitness is going to
form a very important part of the regime
of both players who are playing the
world champion you need to be in peak
form
to be able to handle such a match
deceptive thank you for the prime
you far be it for me to tell either an
upper magnus what to do
kicked under the tables common slamming
pieces is common
i mean i'm sure fist fights have
happened in the history of chess but
it's incredibly uncommon
oh yeah definitely some some gm's not
many
um i'm sure you could find somebody who
like has questionable behavior some
younger
gm's like kids have but they usually
outgrow it
um i don't i've never played a gm who
misbehaved at the board because it's
contrary to like the code
you just don't do that as a gm but the
game has begun so let's watch
i'm gonna refresh so the clock actually
ticks
um one game left
um one game left
and magnus has to win this one with
black to tie the match
draw is a wesley win so wesley playing a
very
oh parents for sure i've seen parents
fight at tournaments but never the kids
in scholastic tournaments the parents
fight all the time which is very ironic
but the kids are always very friendly to
each other
for the most part
all right so we have a very peaceful
bishop b5 check this is the moscow
variation wesley not going for the main
line of the sicilian
um magnus going knight d7 which is the
very combative option bishop d7
is considered to be more uh peaceful
knight d7 is the way to play for a win
we have just sort of a classic position
here
now d4 yeah i'll talk about the world
championship preparations afterward you
can play d4 here and transpose to sort
of a
open ceiling type position i've seen
people do that you can also go knight c3
first
um
so i guess d4 is the most
straightforward move and then you get
sort of a weird
hedgehog type position like this which
resembles a
scavenge again i don't love this for
white though
i don't love that position right you
could also go see okay see yeah i was
going to say c3 or c4
c4 he goes for sort of this marotzi bind
bishop b7 knight c3 and then he wants to
play d4 so magnus could
in theory play e5 on the other hand this
gets a pretty symmetrical central pawn
structure which could be pretty bad for
his winning chances he goes 95
which is also common in these positions
um
and the idea is that if you take the
knight play d takes e5 and
black institutes total control over the
d4 square and black gets the d file for
his queen
so that compensates for the double pawns
wesley still takes on e5
and goes d3 now
i think wesley i like magnus's position
i think he's done a good job in the
opening
wesley playing a3 perhaps trying to
prepare b4
uh maybe chipping into black's uh
central bind
one thing that is in black's favor here
is you can see the double pawns this e6
pawn is protecting the d5 square
white has no equivalent protection of
the d4 score so wesley has to find
counter play elsewhere
notice by the way that the pawn was
untouchable because of queen a4 check
that was a nice tactical detail
wesley expediting uh the process here
magnus drops the knight back to d7
giving some support to this pawn
queen c7 and rook d8 seemed like seems
like a pretty natural setup here
uh eventually magnus could try to get
the knight around to d4
but that's far in the future you can't
play
knight b8 here because of bc and then
the bishop on b7 is going to hang
so i queen c7 looks like the most
natural move to me
f5 can also be considered in such
positions
there's queen c7 wesley probably going
to move the queen himself somewhere
maybe queen b3
[Music]
um i don't know queen b3 seems natural
it's the sort of position where it's
hard for either side to really do
anything rook b2 maybe he wants to go
like this queen
b1 um it's quite clear that white's play
is down the b
file so there's rookie d8
by magnus at some point magnus could
just say to hell with it play f5 but
f5 could always be met with f3 this is
not dangerous for white
this could end up backfiring
so pretty low key position i i mean
i think wesley is in perfectly good
shape here uh notice this d3 pawn folks
this bishop on f1 you always
hear the phrase bad bishops defend good
pawns is a great example of that
you might think this is a terrible
bishop magnus is better versatile
magnus's light square bishop is sort of
biting on granite to use my favorite
expression second of all
this bishop does an excellent job
protecting white's main weakness so
magnus is changing the structure
he takes and goes a5 this is a example
of carving out
if wesley goes b5 that would be bad
positionally because look at these dark
squares
bishop b4 would be possible maybe he
still does it but i don't think so
knight c5
not to mention that this gives black
connected protected passer
so wesley could get the knight into b5
but b takes a5 seems more reasonable
just to keep things
a little bit more open and then perhaps
pile onto this b6 spawn of queen b1
yep takes what magnus takes with the
pawn magnus takes for the pun
one set guys
okay so magnus takes with a pawn wesley
thinking here
it's five plus three now
i guess magnus's idea is to intercept
with bishop b4
so wesley going knight b5 attacking the
queen magnus drops it back
i i like wesley's position here this
pawn perhaps working in black's favor
it's a passed pawn
um of course skippity my pleasure queen
to c2 wesley
probably preparing to double rooks
making sure this pawn is a little bit
better protected magnus could go knight
c5
could still go bishop b4 but white's
position
lacking weaknesses which um is in west i
mean and very active look at this knight
look at these rooks nicely positioned on
the open files
magnus a little bit passive here in
terms of winning chances
this is not looking great i think that
maybe knight c5 here
should be played but this doesn't even
threaten anything
um uh this is
botvinnik like structure this really
doesn't have a specific name
uh but it is not that bad i mean because
this d4 square is well protected
i'm not seeing too many winning chances
here for black maybe bishop c5 trying to
get control of the dark squares
should be considered i would probably
even take
white here if i had a choice in a
classical game
black is just passive the rooks are not
connected there's no place to put the
queen
imbalance just means like knight against
bishop or
anything that's not symmetrical pawn
structure and bounce piece and balance
two rooks against the queen is an
imbalance that's all it is
um i guess bishop b4 makes sense here
you know lending some support to the
pawn but wesley could even drop the
bishop back to d2 trade the bishops
magnus dipping on the clock this is
looking dire in terms of
his winning chances
but we all know what magnus is capable
if that's a typical magnus of h6
trying to get wesley maybe to over
commit
wesley might play h3 here but i don't
like h3 as much because then magnus will
play f5
um so wesley
you know he magnus is hoping that he's
going to burn some clock
agonizing over what his plans should be
yeah bishop b2 is good i mean you could
also you could make a neutral move if
you're white you could even play
f3 which i know looks whoa 97
that's crazy that's beautiful move
because where does the bishop go
that's an incredible move i mean queen
c7 is probably i think magnus missed
this
i guess queen c7 is forced that's a
pretty stunning move maybe it's not that
amazing but
uh it's very pretty looking yup and
wesley repeating with knight b5
magnus is probably going to take it and
i think wesley wants to take with the
pawn
and offer a queen trade which you can't
really refuse because the queen's going
to swoop into c6
wesley looking to bail out here knight
a7 is a very nice find
um clock continues to tick
i don't see an alternative to taking on
b5 i just don't
isn't black uh life squared bishop
compare bad compared to the knight
it is but the point is that when the
position transforms you get other
advantages from that
uh you know trading a good piece for a
bad piece
might be bad in a vacuum but it gives
you other stuff like the beef the you
know like a past beef on magnus going
queen c8
knight a7 he wants to put the queen on
a6 instead
um wesley couldn't even do this but then
after rook fc8
you can't repeat anymore so i think now
might be the time for wesley to
plan a general improving move
um yeah karpov and sacred for sure
d4 is interesting i don't love that
though maybe just double on the a file
rook a2
uh bishop d2 also possible yeah bishop
d2 i really like just going after this
apon
um even queen well queen e2 there might
be bishop b4
thank you uh habib maich for the five
months
wesley wisely taking his time this is an
important moment
i think if wesley can choose the right
approach he will essentially secure the
drought western going h3 now it's his
turn
to make a waiting move get magnus is
basically asking magnus all right
uh what you're going to do to me f5 is
the reason that i didn't like this
earlier but
after f3 there's no attack on the king's
side black has no pieces there
this could end up backfiring and with a
minute on his clock this is an
incredibly smart decision by wesley
magnus having a very hard time here
finding ways to continue the game next
to c5 played
i like this move we've mentioned it
earlier but queen
queen c3 comes to mind as one way to hit
both pawns
problem is that you might not be able to
take e5 because of bishop f6
skewering the rooks rook beat a2
doubling on the a5 is what he chooses
and this is a good move because if you
go a4 then
you allow something like this black has
compensation for the pawn but probably
not more than that
magnus does play a4 not that wesley has
to take on c5 that that's not forced
i also like queen c3 here um
but since he played rook ba1 he probably
wants to take on no queen c3
b3 magnus getting his knight in there
but wait a second you got to be careful
because if rook b1
wesley might have just blundered i think
wesley has to go knight a7 here
wesley might have to go knight a7
because if you move the rook you'll
allow bishop takes b5 and the queen is
unprotected
uh oh knight a7 played this is still
okay for white i think but that's not
what wesley wanted now after queen a6
then queen takes b3 happens so magnus
has to be careful queen to d7 for that
reason
if knight takes c6 queen c6 that
knight's very strong
you could get something like this going
on pawn on a4 is passed
takes takes happens uh-oh
this is not wesley definitely missed
that the knight on b5 was vulnerable
rook b1 you could also play bishop c5
and try to get the bishops off the board
now i'm a little bit worried for
wesley's position but the clock is not
magnus's friend
one idea for wesley here to get smoke
this night out of b3 is to go bishop b2
and then bishop d1
immediately contest and attack that
knight so magnus has really only one or
two tempe
to manufacture something in the center
on the queen side i don't see what it
could be that wesley is still very solid
here
and he's a minute up on the clock knight
to d4 by magnus
sacking the pawn he wants opposite
colored bishops because the queens are
still on the board when the queens are
on the board
opposite-colored bishops could actually
benefit the attacker wesley going for an
ambitious move
undermining the knight will magnus just
play f6 here it seems a little bit
awkward i don't see an alternative
neither does magnus he plays f6
uh now if you take the pawn you don't
want to do that because of bishop c5 so
both kings are weakened
maybe wesley just drops the king to h1
or something you could also play bishop
p2 that other idea of bishop etubishopd1
i don't like f4 i feel like that weakens
white's king more than it weakens
black's king
i think wesley is panicking just a
little bit
wesley is panicking just a little bit
here
this is bad for white yeah f4 was a big
mistake f4 was definitely a very big
mistake i think
maybe i'm wrong i'm not i'm not looking
at the engine as you guys know
uh but it appears that wesley
underestimated how weak his king would
be
i don't see what to do i think you got
to go bishop b2
the clock's now equalizing but magnus
wants to go rook b8 he wants to go
a3 fixed upon wesley taking it now he's
not going to take the pawn
queen to c2 now a3 this looks terrible
for white magnus might win this
can wesley build some sort of maginot
line c5 trying to give up the pawn
get some breathing room for his pieces
magnus can take with the queen he can
take with the bishop i'm not sure which
way he should take i think bishop takes
us better
what wesley i think wants to do now he
takes to the queen but now queen b3
maybe
i don't know maybe you trade queens and
pray
rage i don't know this is bad that pawn
on a3
what makes it terrible for white is the
fact that that pawn is on a dark square
and white has no dark squared bishop
there is no way to attack and win that
pawn
wesley does take but now rook v8 looks
totally devastating magnus plays it
if you trade then after bishop d1 rook
b1 this wins the bishop the game
is almost over here's infiltration this
is losing
rook a1 is forced oh bishop g4 by wesley
oh that's a very clever move but f5
boom intercepting the bishop and now
it's over magnus is going to win
unbelievable on this this is over
everything is hanging
and wesley loses and agnes ties the
match can you believe that
wow that's incredible incredible
it is insane to win from that position
he was on his back foot i mean after
wesley went knight a7
it seemed like i mean of course magnus
didn't have to repeat moves but it just
seemed like wesley is so solid
his position is unassailable and somehow
that's why this guy's world champion i
mean nobody
in chess history has been able to do
that with such regularity
and against such a level of opposition
as magnus carlson
this is what makes him special is this
ability to pull out wins from these
kinds of positions not the only thing of
course
um no the turning point was before i
think the turning point was wesley
not taking on c5 i think he had to do
this
i'm going to bet that this would have
been no
no still worse according to the computer
takes takes f5
and i guess magnus has very strong
compensation here
so that's not it according to the engine
let's see
well first of all you should have
definitely grabbed the pawn you should
have definitely grabbed the pawn even
though white is worse here
there's better drawing chances but the
mistake came before
so according to the engine yeah so there
it is
h3 this waiting move which seems very
innocuous it allows black to position
the knight in the center
and instead wesley had to go bishop d2
going immediately after this pawn
um i think we may have discussed to some
of bishop d2 going after the pun
and it's plus equals i mean black has no
winning chances here this would have
secured the match
um this would have secured the match
because
bishop d8 but look at how passive this
move is
and at the very least white can just
repeat moves like this
and if you take on b5 you can take with
the rook of the spawn is toast
and once this pawn is lost and there's
just no chances to lose
i don't know if there was a force draw i
don't know if there was a force draw you
could also have taken and gone rook b5
uh which which leads basically to almost
an unlosable position
but it's very easy in hindsight
obviously to say how could wesley have
not played it
i think f4 was a mistake on top of
everything else f4
brought the position from bad to worse
but to be honest i think magnus would
have won this anyway i think after
bishop c5 and
rook fda with this amazing pawn look at
the control over the dark squares
i feel like this is very hard to defend
in a blitz game even if this is equal
according to the computer
i think f4 exacerbated it because of how
much it weakens the king
but it it uh the damage was done before
no bishop d4 was not a draw um this this
this would not have led to a force drop
white is worse here much worse from an
objective standpoint
for sure uh because of the control over
the dark squares and this a pawn
thank you my pleasure yeah this is a lot
of fun
so what you guys have to realize okay
i'm gonna see magnus's reaction on my
phone
um let me see if i can is there a clip
of it that somebody could put in the
put in the chat it felt like a marks and
spencer adverts
yeah and look at how nervous he is
there's that five the white rook trying
to eliminate the blockade of black's
porn why is bishop trying to cause some
chaos threatening to take bomb with
check but magnus blocking the white
bishop
is that just game over here there's
nothing to be done one second
in the piece magnus fights back wow
look at that reaction from magnus
carlsen it is a comeback from the world
champion
he wins the second blitz trying to
undermine let's watch that again
eliminate the blockade of black's pawn
why is bishop trying to cause some chaos
threatening to take bomb with check
but magnus blocking the white bishop is
that just game over here
there's nothing to be done one second
magnus fights back wow look at that
reaction from magnus carlsen that's
awesome
that's awesome wesley wesley is super
low-key too
um that's awesome um
but i mean i'm not surp why are people
surprised i mean i think that's a
natural reaction
um i mean people do that when they hit a
three-pointer
like in at the start of a game
this is magnus like saving the match um
it's kind of like watching steph curry
do this because he does this so rarely
uh give me shelter thank you i want i
think chess needs a lot more of that
chess needs a lot more of those kinds of
reactions
i mean he's not doing it in wesley's
face this isn't
over the board but i think that that's
awesome
okay so we're waiting for the armageddon
game to begin
this is going to be maximum oh and it
started there we go
so wesley with four minutes magnus with
five i'm gonna refresh
the clock's tick and if black makes a
draw then the match is over then wesley
wins as you guys know we have an italian
we're gonna we're always looking from
white's perspective
um not because i like magnus more it's
just
standard stuff
all right so we have a mainline italian
there is no increment here as i am as
far as i remember there is no increment
in armageddon
that's just the rule this is a must win
for magnus b4 this is the new move
you're grabbing space on the queen side
often times you'll see
b4 and a4 you're threatening a5 to win
the bishop wesley's got to play a6 he
does
and sometimes white even gets the knight
out to the side knight a3 kind of like
this
just to keep the diagonal for the bishop
open or you could play as far as i
remember you could push a5
and grab even more space now magnus
plays knight bd2
okay d6 by wesley wesley decides against
going d5 which is the sort of sharp
continuation
which is understandable he's got less
time but magnus really taking his time
here in the opening
i'm a bit surprised as the time
advantage is down to 30 seconds
magnus is not sure what to do here if he
goes rookie one that's the typical
approach rookie one night upon maybe
he's afraid of knight g4
um it seems like he's a little bit out
of his no he's gone rookie one and
wesley went 97
c6 is a good fall magnus striking with
d4 oftentimes black gets the knight to
g6 here
black could also take it and go d5 i've
seen this kind of reaction as well
um and wesley i think is going to do
that and i like black's position here i
don't like what magnus has done in the
opening
i think yep d5
and you know the problem here is that
you get an iqp isolated queen pun but no
but e5 by magnus
oh that's a nice move the only way to
avoid getting that nasty iqp position
that's a very nice move if you take the
bishop white takes the knight and
black's king side pawn structure is
going to be ruined
after g takes f6 knight c4 wesley may
have missed that move and i did as well
i'll be honest with you
i completely overlooked that now what to
do here for wesley if he moves the night
then white's driven this very nice pawn
wedge
into black's position then magnus is
gonna be better for sure
okay wesley deciding how to play here he
could take
and then move the knight somewhere
trying to secure his king here maybe
knight g6 but i don't like this either
that c4 pawn is going to be lost
um iqp is good for the side that
blockades the square in front of it
knight h5 wesley i think is trying to
swing the knight over i like this
decision he's going to swing the knight
over to f4 and perhaps to e6
it looks like knight f4 has to be played
otherwise this knight could get
stranded he does and then perhaps 96
blockading the pawn but definitely black
is worse here knight g6
defending the knight trying to keep it
on an active square
magnus has more space on the queen side
he could play queen c2 here
um he could play bishop e3 developing
the bishop he goes a5 grabbing more
space on the king
on the queen side remember that there's
no increment here
so flagging becomes a very significant
part of the equation
wesley has to be careful this is looking
quite comfortable for white black is not
losing i like the way wesley handled e5
as you guys know the knights are very
good when they're blockading important
pawns
magnus has to be watchful of this pawn
on d4 another thing to watch out for
wesley could play f6 at some point
and try to open up the file which would
be in his favor because magnus doesn't
have a rook on f1
um so we had a trade bishop f4 knight f4
and queen d2
agnes trading his bish i'm a little bit
surprised
a little bit surprised um i assume you
lost randon
that's okay uh knight g6
knight c5 magnus positioning his knight
on that outpost now wesley with the
decision if wesley takes magnus is going
to play bc
and get the b file open and then attack
this b-pawn wesley going f6 there it is
now a decision for magnus does he take
no he plays bishop d3 attacking the
knight the knight has to move this is
very dubious for black look at how nice
this knight is
white's entire position is breathing
wesley might have to go f5 and shut
things down
but then look at that pawn and e5 it'll
be a monster wesley does play five
does magnus play e6 here is that over
ambitious
that could backfire if that pawn becomes
a weakness on the other hand you could
try something like this
that seems very tempting maybe there's
no need to rush maybe you play rookie
two double your rooks on the
on the e5 magnus playing a very magnus
type move dropping the bishop maybe
moving into b3
uh just solidifying his control over the
position wesley
is pushed uh wesley is on his back foot
he's on the ropes g3 by magnus may be
preparing to push this knight out of g6
with h4 this is a pretty typical idea
h4 h5 magnus doesn't have to worry about
his king
because black has absolutely nothing to
attack it with on the king's side
this is looking very bad for wesley as
he's down 40 seconds
the moment he moves the knight back
magnus could try attacking this pawn on
f5
wesley takes and plays bishop e6 we're
anticipating something like h4
magnus could also play rook ab1 first
attacking this pawn from all sides
from africa from south america
rook ab1 happens tying down at least one
of black's pieces to the defense of that
pawn
h4 comes in um from the other side
magnus could also double his rooks rook
b2 he could also play rookie three
oh there it is he's swinging the rook
around to b3 look at how he's attacking
on both sides
first using this weakness and now knight
h for striking on the other side
he wants wesley to play g5 that would be
way too weakening magnus would say thank
you very much get back to f3 and then
sack a knight there
wesley is just paralyzed here but will
magnus
deliver the final blow the knight
swinging around to f4 trying to dislodge
this bishop from e6 bishop to d3
is another idea in these types of
positions taking on a6
would be a threat i think bishop d3 is
very strong here
but wesley preparing to put a knight on
c6 maybe i like knight for h4 bishop a4
forcing the trade i don't know if magnus
should have allowed this
i don't like magnus allowing that trade
that is a small win i think for wesley
because that light squared bishop for
white
was responsible for pressuring the f5
pawn still very bad for wesleys he's
down 40 seconds and he's got a minute
left
there's no increment this is looking
very rough for him the times are not
exactly accurate but wesley could try
knight d8
maybe then get the knight to e6 no g5
kind of a last-ditch attempt to mix
things up magnus closing down the center
f4
look at how weak black's king is magnus
could play king f2 and rook h1 on top of
everything else
wesley tries to beat him to the punch
king g7 i would simply take on g5 here
and play knight f4 perhaps
but i think after fg maybe wesley wants
f4
and then queen g4 some sort of a last
ditch attempt no magnus goes king f2
or h8
um f takes g5 as possible at any point
but
both kings are kind of weak here and
wesley is the first one to the h vowel
infiltrating to h2 one minute on the
clock here wesley with 51 seconds
magnus getting his queen in to defend
knight takes d4 is not
concerning because queen takes d5
happens and then b7 is weak on top of
everything else
40 seconds now for wesley yep this
happens
will he drop the knight back to c6 i
don't see an alternative
30 seconds now e6 looks incredibly
strong here
creating the threat of queen takes f5
this is losing
for wesley will he pull a miracle e6 is
played queen to d8 remember draw
uh benefits what draw wins the match for
wesley so magnus
he's got to think twice about the queen
trade he trades on his own terms queen
d7 he wants a pass spawn here
rook d a if anything if nothing else
magnus could go for the flag here
take on b7 everything starts to fall c7
is gonna fall
this is completely winning for magnus
rook takes c7 and c6
looks like he's about to win and wesley
has resigned and magnus wins
unbelievable what a game
what a comeback what a freaking comeback
that's insane
magnus coming back from one point down
turning around
a worse position in the second game than
winning the armageddon with white
incredible performance and he's going to
uh the doubters are going to be silent
for at least a day
right wow
i'm sure magnus is thrilled we need the
reaction
okay just let i can find it if you want
but unless there is something pretty
special then
it's not worth watching and the reason
wesley resigned is because
first of all he's got like 10 seconds
two magnus's minute
and then c6 and d7 and with c8 this is
over
yeah now we also have to pay attention
to the clock yeah because the west is
down to 26
26 seconds and uh
the clock is a big ah no now it's clock
is not even important yeah
magnus is going crazy look at this how
he's celebrating
wow that's awesome oh my god
and then the aftershock
oh my god oh my god magnus carlsen does
it
he does it vito he wins and that's
always
such a clutch player and a very
disappointed west leader and
yeah that's uh i love that that's
awesome
that's awesome
i think that that reaction is very
natural i would be surprised if he
didn't have some sort of reaction like
that
why wouldn't they celebrate like that
over the board for the simple reason
that the opponent is sitting there and
you're in a playing hall where you have
to be silent
um here you're alone in your apartment
or house and
um your opponent's not seeing you so
it's a very completely different sorry
and i've seen these kinds of
celebrations over the board
like a little fist up fist bump is fine
when you win like the world championship
or something
well seeing each other online would be
distracting they have to play the game
this is not the same thing i'm sure
i'm sure like they can watch each
other's camera it's probably a zoom call
i mean
it's probably a zoom call but i don't
think that that they were fixated on it
in time pressure
magnus would never do that over the
board but on a camera it's totally fine
i think and it's actually really cool
yeah i hope nobody's thinking it's like
disrespect or something on on
on in this kind of tournament it's
totally fine i think